hello hello 6 43 welcome back everybody
happy monday to you i'm monica jackson
and it is time for mondays with monica
this week we're talking about working
from home and how to handle double duty
mom and dad you're picking up what i'm
putting down yeah a lot of people have
been parenting with their kiddos at home
while trying to work
virtually and here to talk more about
that is chris tamora he's an executive
director of hr at a biotech company and
also
an instructor over at unlv how you doing
chris good morning
good morning it's nice to be on mondays
with monica monica
well it's nice to have you here my
friend thank you so much for coming all
right let's get right into these tips
now chris you know everybody has been
doing segments about this but your tips
are a little different that's why i
wanted to bring it let's get right into
it and then i'll double back and ask you
a couple questions about two or three of
them go ahead
absolutely so the first one is when
presenting on a conference call make
sure to establish rules
one of the reasons why i chose this
background of a door
is to make sure that in case there's a
distraction you're able to
to cover those distractions and and be
able to
maneuver through the signals whether
it's a cough whether it's covering the
door
or being able to um communicate somehow
to the family that you're on an
important call
okay all right and number two number two
is try and schedule breaks where
where um you can take walks with the
family remember those morning drives
where the traffic is kind of heavy but
it gives you a little bit of that time
to
decompress the most important part is to
be able to decompress
while in the four walls of your home
which is also serves as you work which
serves as your school
and being able to to kind of take a
moment breathe relax
and take everyone out of the four walls
okay now this third one i i kind of took
issue with but i'll let you go ahead
i'll double back on this one go ahead so
to
do not apologize for distractions yeah
hello
chris that's rude
well the important thing is everyone has
a barking dog or an animal
or a child or a parent that may
um have additional needs and what we
want to do is not apologize
keep going with your call keep
continuing no matter how big or small
those distractions are
because everyone is in the same boat you
know what and they make for great
videos you've seen those you know going
on ever since the shutdown happened
but okay you say uh also the next one is
understand that you are not alone
in adapting to this environment i think
that one's a big deal
because a lot of people are dealing with
loneliness especially our elderly folks
but for
working class mom and dad you know it
can feel like you're alone because it's
so isolating right now
oh absolutely and you know we're so used
to that human contact just walking by
someone's office or walking
through a school and doing all these
different activities and and
stopping that does change our mind frame
and how we think about work
how we think about just our everyday
activities and being able to know that
we're in it together and trying to find
ways such as zoom calls
or or getting on the phone is so much
more personable now than emails are even
now
yeah okay this last one uh in the words
of
sweet brown you know that video that
went viral when she said ain't nobody
got time for that
chris how the heck do you take a virtual
vacation and recharge we're in the midst
of a pandemic
yes we are ben um your vacation hours
are adding up so you want to make sure
that you take your vacation hours
and you don't necessarily have to go
anywhere but imagine yourself at beverly
hills and doing some window shopping
online
[Laughter]
going to hawaii being able to look at
the beach there's zoom backgrounds for
the
the hawaii backgrounds yeah there's so
many different ways to take a virtual
vacation
oh my gosh okay chris you're gonna have
to elaborate a little bit more on that
one
because i mean seriously with the kids
running around and i'm not making fun of
you you know how i am but
with the kids running around you trying
to focus you
how do you take a virtual vacation i got
30 seconds you got to sell this one
you have to turn your mind off to all
the chaos and turn your mind on to
something pleasant
and sometimes the chaos is pleasant but
being able to go around and look around
and say this is my vacation
this is where i want to be imagine that
island and try to be on that island
oh yeah i'm gonna take a virtual
vacation on an island this morning chris
did i sell you on it not really not
really we'll talk later hey you're the
hr guy you're the expert you know this
stuff is good thank you so much and i
hope parents i hope that helped you guys
out i really
uh am trying to give you information
because i know it's really tough right
now
and so we'll keep bringing it to you be
sure to catch mondays with monica every
monday right here
on eight news now next week we're going
to be talking
to a famous comedian mr george wallace
yeah baby so make sure to tune in i
can't wait to see my friend haven't
talked to him in a long time 6 48
sherry i know you know george as well i
do i love george i haven't seen him in a
long long while it'll be fun to talk to
him
monica this is how i communicated at
home you know when we all worked at home
yeah i was like can't you see i'm on tv
[Laughter]
i was only talking to the cat and the
dog because ethan's away at school and
everybody's doing their own thing in the
house but